okay I have to do this podcast so what's
the name of the podcast and allies Asia
I'm ready I'm obsessed with the notion
of all of us who are listening right now
want to achieve something whether we
want to sell something whether we want
to run for government whether we want
somebody to know about our daughter's
music skills and the way you do that is
by getting somebody's attention and then
telling them something I am fascinated
by podcasts by Facebook Ads by KO ELLs
by all the different things happening in
the world in all the regions and I think
some things are very overpriced you know
Direct Mail billboards television
commercials and I think some things are
under priced for mentioned Kol so that's
what I do and along the way I've built
my brand quite a bit I've written for
New York Times bestselling books and I
give keynote speeches all over the world
including one here today in Singapore I
told you it's very interesting that you
mentioned care kol because the opinion
leader is the term that's used in China
so your understanding of China is
probably pretty interesting yeah I mean
look I you know as you know and now to
update all of you I've been very
thoughtful of entering the Asian market
mainland China until we were talking
earlier I like many Americans do think
of it as mainland China then I put Japan
and Korea into a bucket and then I think
about the rest but I'm very aware of
Singapore and Malaysia Jakarta things
that I think about it thoughtfully I you
know I pride myself in being open-minded
and thoughtful I think American business
men and women tend to be close-minded
were very insular you know it's
something people don't understand about
Americans so I've been very thoughtful
over the last four or five years paying
close attention I was an angel investor
and path so I obviously I knew a lot of
what was going on here and again I you
know I I think that there's so much a
real pure bred entrepreneurial spirit in
the overall Asian market that I've been
watching from afar early this year I
took my first trip to Hong Kong now I'm
here in Singapore vaynermedia has really
a mission to open an office here I have
ambition to be in mainland China twice
next year Japan Korea Malaysia so yes I
do have an understanding and there's
obviously many things that the mainland
China companies are further
and in the US markets and there's also
uniqueness in Southeast Asia
you know platforms of execution that I'm
always paying attention to because I try
to figure out do they make sense in an
American environment how are our
citizens different what are the
infrastructure differences but yeah I
really want to win and I think you can't
win in the next 40 years without being
thoughtful in every part of the world
including Africa and South America and
things of that nature I have enjoyed
books because you always thought about
social media as a way to grab attention
yes you think about how to get customers
to come to with your very customer
centric yes points oh I only have two
questions please remove that that did
the rest of the more interesting stuff
can you share about how you think of
social media that has evolved from the
past to debating and what are your
favorite social media tools so I think
the only thing that's evolved it you
know and if you read crush it which I
wrote in 2008 came out in 2009 and I'm
as big a buyer of this revolution as
anybody and I'm glad I put it on paper
right so I think the only thing that's
really changed is nobody doubts it
anymore this is changing governments and
society and propaganda in a way that now
it's you know I laugh when people I have
business meetings where people literally
spend the first 20 minutes talking about
Russia invading America through its
Facebook's and this is then and then all
of a sudden we get to marketing and they
tell me Facebook's not that big they
should still do television I'm like wait
a minute what about the first 20 minutes
when you said our entire governments
being overthrown by social media but now
to sell your blouses or your soda it's
not important so I think the only thing
that's changed is people's acceptance of
it and it's scale my favorite right now
is definitely Instagram because of its
flexibility and because of its
overwhelming attention and because if
you're trying to sell something to
somebody 20 to 45 it is the platform
along with Facebook but a little bit
more because under 27 it's got so much
more juice than Facebook and that that
is you know obviously in all the markets
that Instagram is and some some of the
people listening here it has not
penetrated that market but that is my
favorite right now I enjoy your books
one of the things is
you're the way you think about business
pragmatism and of course the story of
your family business so I wanted to talk
about your two books freshening
askgaryvee and since you're here
so in askgaryvee I know in the first app
chapter you talked about the closet as a
metaphor looking at high-level
principles such as bring that it's a
customer always play the long game of
lifetime value can you talk about how do
they guide you in terms of how you think
and how you execute because you you seem
to be able to reach it pretty quickly
and you feel the execution is really the
key to everything
so it's super interesting I'm really
enjoy this is such a great way to start
my trip I just want everybody know I'm
about to pay your host here a huge
compliment we don't know each other but
I have a funny feeling we're gonna know
each other for a very long time I meet a
lot of people I wish I I have the film
so if any of you guys maybe we'll maybe
we'll send it to you and you can use it
for another podcast
you said something now in your question
I'm listening to the way you're asking
questions and then obviously I have the
benefit of last hour and realizing how
thoughtful you are something that I'm
becoming more in tune with is I'm the
most consumer centric thing that I know
of other people other businesses I'm
watching how two of my partners in crime
Reisen David Dirac just reacted I'm
unbelievably consumer centric so clouds
and dirt my thesis is if you care more
about the end consumer than you care
about your own self you will win so I
talked a lot about 5149 for people that
really follow my content I really live
it I really genuinely live it I never
make short-term financial decisions I'm
always trying to bring more value to the
other party I do that for a couple
reasons number one I think I'm talented
enough to get quite a bit in my 49 I
also think it's unbelievable leverage I
also think it's a nice legacy I think
it's nice to do I think it's a nice
legacy to have and I do that with my
interpersonal relationships and I
definitely do that with my businesses so
my principles guide everything you're
right executions everything and I think
what's interesting about the clouds and
dirt Mehta
or is it helps people paint a picture of
what I'm most worried about which is I
believe 99% of people listen to this
podcast spend an ungodly amount of time
in the middle um I'll give you an
example of something in the middle
process process is held on such a
pedestal in modern business society and
I find not to be in the middle I
understand its value but I do feel that
if you push hard on the clouds your
religion and you push hard on the dirt
the actual doing that the process gets
commoditized and you go faster and so
yes I have principles of bringing more
value the lifetime value attention
arbitrage as I mentioned earlier and
then you know I'm never too fancy to do
I mean I will be honest with you I think
even this 30 minutes is a good example
of that
I didn't over ask ERISA I have no clue
how many people listen to your podcast
I'm never in a place where I think I'm
too fancy to do the work and I take a
lot of pride that I'm a practitioner I
understand Facebook and snapchat
Instagram these platforms better than
most because I use them multiple times
every day 365 days a year I think it's a
huge competitive Vantage and I think I
think the you know I obviously you
mentioned earlier HBS and Harvard you
know I think the thing that I've learned
is not a good student and as an executor
now that I'm 41 on the verge of being 42
years old is man a lot of things break
down between theory and execution and I
am I'm absolutely obsessed with
execution and I do think that theory at
a lot of times sits in the middle I
think you have to push yourself to the
clouds to a bigger calling and I think
there's no better calling than the end
consumer if you're building a consumer
product there's a loss out there
dreaming about becoming Union constant
you have been the investor of unicron's
but I also understand you have a very
different perspectives of business
because I've heard a couple of
interviews particularly the recent one
on Rico so Asia a little bit about your
philosophies particularly in becoming
sustainable focusing on top line revenue
in optimizing for profit yeah I think
it's a great question and we got to
speak to it a little bit before as well
just I'm just trying to make all of you
who are listening jealous that you
missed out on so much good stuff before
we started the podcast I'll try to fill
you in yeah I think again and I'm gonna
give you a compliment the fact that use
consumer centric and used practicality I
feel like a lot of people are confused
by me I think I do a very good job
building a persona that makes it a
little bit of an enigma the fact that
you've been able to synthesize me makes
me think you're smart which is
interesting and I and I guess this is
what it comes down to my friends we are
living through the greatest era of
financial arbitrage machines when I hear
a unicorn you know yes there's no
companies that have been successful but
to me I'm worried because I think most
of the people that are deemed unicorns
that I are just rhinoceroses wearing
outfits that look like a unicorn because
a lot of the current unicorns are not
sustainable with a macro economic
slowdown and so you know you brought up
a great point which is it may not be the
way we manipulate economies it may be
something like war or something else
that creates a need for liquid that will
force a correction I think that's
exactly astute observation and to me the
question is very simple so for example
the business I run today it's 150
million dollar a year revenue business
it makes some level of profit this
you're the least that it ever has
however if [ __ ] got difficult next year
even during the Great Depression brands
advertised right not everybody goes out
of business if [ __ ] hits the fan
tomorrow every brand in the world is
gonna start scrutinizing how it spends
its marketing dollars I believe if every
brand lost half of its marketing budget
next year everyone that my company would
grow 10x because they would have to
scrutinize where they spend their money
and spending it with us is far better
than spending it with you know with WPP
agencies that want to sell highly
profitable television and programmatic
banners so for me
King about that I think a lot of the
unicorns are not profitable and they
need the next round of capital and if
that goes away their businesses break
and so I'm yelling because it's too late
for you know Spotify or or ubers or all
these big companies they're on their way
they've they're they're on their way but
there's a lot of young kids who are in
the middle
who are raising their a or their B who
have no thought none of actually
building a business what they're trying
to do is build a big enough valuation so
that under third fundraising round they
can take money off the table the fact
that there are kids who are able to get
to a C and D round and are able to take
tens and hundreds of millions of dollars
off the table without ever building a
successful business is clearly
attractive that's fine for a founder or
two but when the [ __ ] hits the fan
that's not going to be good for the
investors and more importantly in my
opinion the employees and and I have a
problem with that supposed to do you can
give tell your 20 year old self
something on business what would be the
I should give him that you should not
it's in question I would say that your
intuition is right that as long as you
don't die this is a marathon and it's a
hell of a lot better to train for a
marathon than a sprint and and that's it
like I you know I can't I'm so grateful
for where I'm sitting today heading into
the prime of my business career with
really deep fundamental skill sets that
will help me navigate through no matter
what happens going forward both
emotionally and in business and so I was
a very unique kid I built a very big
business in my 20s and was still paying
myself $60,000 a year and didn't need
stuff because I wanted to be all-time
great and I kept reinvesting in my
businesses instead of buying watches and
sneakers and cars and I wouldn't really
want to say too much because I would be
scared if I said something that kid
would do something differently than he
did since we are in Asia that most
business are actually driven by family
and one of the things I actually
identify when I read askgaryvee is that
used to work in a family business - and
I think that's probably one of the most
interesting and very under taught in
most of your interviews so I want to ask
you what is the experience like and how
do you navigate the dynamics in both
your family so I've been getting in tune
with this a little bit more now that AJ
is left vaynermedia is probably the
first time I've really operated in some
pseudo capacity of not having family
with me in my entire career even though
AJ's still on the you know cap table and
things of that nature and I still talk
to him about it
no to his credit he never asks and lets
me do my thing it's probably the thing
I'm most proud of I think when people
look back at my career and and and dig
under the hood which you know even me
saying that speaks to the audacity that
I have and I want to be an all time
entrepreneur I really do but not because
I say it because I execute I'm very
proud that from 22 to 34
I built my dad's business for him hey
look to give you the answer for
everybody so sin/cos is very hard the
reason I've been able to make family
businesses work is because I love my dad
and brother more than I like money
it's just really not complicated
family businesses are difficult because
it's your choosing between family and
money let's make it very binary you can
be you can pull over on the side of the
road right now you can turn off your
treadmill you can stop walking your dog
I promise you that's all it's happening
it's the love of your family member
versus the money and what's overlaid and
the hardest part is pride or the score
as I call it my biggest problem hasn't
been the money it's been the competitive
nature of trying to figure out who's
better me and my dad me and my brother
the thing that has been most difficult
is the narrative on who's driving the
ship who's the best player on the team
and getting the respect back and forth
and I would say it was easier with my
brother
than it was with my dad as it would that
would make sense but I think the reason
I've been able to be successful is a
little bit of 5149 as I talked about
earlier I do that with my my two family
members but I would say this it is
easily the most difficult thing that I
think most people have to go through
because there's first of all it's hard
enough to build a business when you
overlay the emotional baggage of family
dynamics in securities fairness and I
you know I also only worked with my
brother who was 11 years younger if my
sister had joined the business and she
was three and a half years younger than
me if she joined the wine business that
would have been another dynamic it is
very difficult and I would tell
everybody the following line you've got
to try your best to take a step
back and think about the funeral of the
other individuals and take that into
account the thing that always allowed me
to navigate was I didn't want to be at
my dad's funeral and have regret and I
felt that it was better to leave a lot
of money on the table and better myself
in the long term that I would be able to
close the gap than to have no
relationship with my father and I think
you know for a lot of Asian youngsters I
feel like the Russian and the Asian
family dynamics are far more similar
than let's say a Russian or Asian
dynamic to an American family and so I
think a lot of you gonna understand that
I but I will say this as well
I don't over react either I know your
parents like mine expected respect my
dad wants respect just cuz he's my dad I
think that only goes so far and so if
you want to do something that is good
for you legacy wise and you feel good
about when your parents are no longer in
the picture
I recommend that but um but I think you
also have to draw lines in the sand for
your own pride in your own life and you
have to be okay with making tough
decisions and so I have a lot of empathy
on this subject matter so I want to come
to Vienna media yes you're coming to
Vienna media yes
what inspired you to start vaynermedia
and what is the mission and vision of
your company I want to build the
greatest marketing machine of all time I
call it the death star of marketing it's
why I created a holding company and why
you'll hear me start saying Bane or X
more than vaynermedia cuz vaynermedia is
the agency part but I'm gonna be
building out the publishing part with
Vayner X the vision was very simple I
thought I was a unique
once-in-a-generation marketer I I know
how ridiculous of a statement that is
but I needed to prove it to myself
whether I was right or not and I thought
the best way to do that was to build an
infrastructure and a company around my
skill set and then what I wanted to do
was buy brands and run it through them
the Asian aspect of our expansion and
very much this trip is a little bit
about getting acclimated to Singapore
with an ambition to open an office here
is I just couldn't imagine you know very
tough to have world domination and not
have a have a play in Asia so as I see
the next 30 or 40 years working out in
my career I was invigorated with my trip
to Hong Kong recently and I'm so excited
about this trip is at the beginning of a
two-day trip there is just clearly a
different energy in in entrepreneurship
and business that is a little bit more
in tune with me there's a reason why I
think I can only live in New York and
even at the end this is a ridiculous
thing to say and even at times New York
feels a little slow to me so I'm looking
for that energy that drug of high
intensity high pressure winner attitude
and I feel like Asia intuitively I felt
it and it's been confirmed and I'm
excited to see how I feel in 48 hours
but uh but I'm excited about it so I
know some of your customers because I
went to the website know by Pfizer
Unilever to your major customers but in
specifically in u.s. or Asia globally
who are your customers yeah so we have
fortune 500 companies you know Johnson &
Johnson fortune 500 companies Johnson
Johnson's and Chase and and and
Budweiser a bi and Unilever and and on
and on and on and so Turner Broadcasting
a lot of the TV clients out there in the
u.s. ge these are major companies with
offices all around the world and and a
lot of our expansion is to do with a
little bit of the pressure I feel that
we have to become more global or will
become too one-dimensional you know for
a lot of these companies as you can
imagine America is a huge market but
every day becomes less of the percentage
of their overall business and so we work
with very big brands you know we've
built a division called Vayner beta
we've built a division called Vayner
Talent
so we want to work with smaller
businesses because I don't want to lose
that that those roots but when we come
to Asia it will be focused first on the
Fortune 1000 and then you know call it
20 22 20 23 I can start thinking about
how to
servus small and medium-sized businesses
in the region and the business problems
that your company is trying to solve
other customers well what are they every
company in the world is overspending on
marketing everyone and so we would like
I just want the historical I just want
to be historically correct that I'm
right about that statement I know I am
and I think in hindsight I'll win a lot
of points in history so we are trying to
get our brands to reallocate their
dollars and every market is different
and so the way of Johnson & Johnson or a
Unilever or Budweiser Chase or Toyota
markets in America is gonna be different
than the way they market in Malaysia or
in South Korea and I want to be great at
telling them what to do with their money
and then produce the pictures videos and
written words that help them achieve
their business goals cool so use just
lunches pair of sneakers yeah that about
so this is a super-fun thing you know
for everybody who's in their early 40s
like I am especially if you had the
luxury of growing up in America sneaker
culture is very big globally now but I
was a child of the 80s when the Jordans
and the Ewings and the Barclays and the
Larry Bird's and Magic Johnson's when
sports sneakers became a thing I was
reached out to by k-swiss about a year
and a half ago and they said look adidas
is won by aligning itself with Kanye and
they've won you know urban culture you
know obviously Nike and and Under Armour
are playing in sports culture we think
that entrepreneurship is a new pillar of
fame and we think you're the face for it
and would you consider doing a sneaker
before he finished Barney the
president's case was before he finished
the statement I said yes because it was
a win I always say yes fast when it's
win-win the way I saw it is I also agree
that entrepreneurship is now on a
cultural pedestal I don't think it's
going away anytime soon so I expect
other entrepreneurs to have sneakers and
for me being the first is always
interesting so that was number one and
then number two if it didn't work it
would be a fun you know kind of side
note for me and my buddies to make fun
of my ah
study that I thought I was cool enough
to have a sneaker and they flopped and I
have 5,000 pairs sitting in my garage
that's interesting so you're in Asia now
yes I mean I definitely get the
motivation why you came from the u.s. to
Asia yes since you are in Singapore and
you've been to Hong Kong what is your
first impressions of Asia with these two
seas so my my biggest impression and
I've spent a lot of time also watching
from afar and when I say watching afar
signing in to WeChat sand and cue and
all these things and so it's just a
different level of rawness that I
appreciate and I don't you know I hate
when Americans or Europeans speak - oh
the ethics are not as good it's all
loser talk they're coming up with
excuses I think there's a level of
ambition a level of perseverance and a
level of can-do attitude that is
intoxicating for real entrepreneurs and
and so that is my first impression that
people are hungry and now look I think
China is an incredibly intriguing cloud
and I don't use cloud as a bad thing but
it is a thing that I think you know the
Asian market always thinks about what
are they up to it's a thing and that you
know I think that's intriguing so I
think it's a little early for me to make
a thoughtful statement I bought
cryptocurrency in 2013 and 14 and I'm
still not on the record on my thoughts
on it
so it's tough for me to think about
making my official Asian POV but the
people have been so disproportionally
interesting to me
it's the ambition the ambition is real
yep I totally agree so it comes to the
closing so I want to ask you two things
one is can you recommend something that
has profound influence in your life in
the form of a book podcast or media so
this is a tough question for me I'm a
very unique guy the answer is sure but
it's gonna be a uniquely interesting
answer which is my audience so for exam
I just connected from Hong Kong to
Singapore for our flight I slept so even
though it was nighttime and I was trying
to get tired what did I do
the guy next to me is watching a movie
other people are doing all sorts of
different things on our electronic
devices I spent four straight hours
reading comments from people on my
content so I think the reason that I'm a
good culture consumer-centric strategist
is because I probably spend more time
reading comments than anybody I've ever
heard of so when I used to talk about
and Thank You economy engaged what you
know when I talk about reply to
everybody and things that nature what I
didn't realize in 2011 that I now do in
2017 was I was already reading everyone
so the addition of replying seemed like
a very lightweight ask and that has been
unbelievably effective for me so that
has been my greatest impact on me which
has been the audience itself so I would
definitely check out all the comments I
thought you would know please my last
questionnaire I think this is for me to
you is a dumb question how can my
audience find you they can find almost
everywhere right yes I mean they can i
think you know i am i rana CLE one of
our big strategies is also to build out
my my mainland china profiles as well
but I would say facebook.com slash Gary
or the podcast is being consumed
unbelievably go globally so the Gary Vee
audio experience and a lot of you know
iTunes or Google Play or stitcher
Spotify are things that nature so or you
can Google or search Gary Vee usually
something will pop up
and your bums win it when the fire takes
over
blood is running there as the battle
gets closed